I sometimes think about that army of
sperm cells
however many hundreds of thousands there
are
and I kind of think of all the
possibilities there
because there's a lot of variation and
one gets to win
is is that not a random one is it a
totally ridiculous way to think about no
not at all so I would say evolutionarily
we are a very slow evolving species
basically the generations of humans are
a terrible way to do selection what you
need is processes that allow you to do
selection in a smaller tighter Loop yeah
and part of what
if you look at our immune system for
example
it evolves at a much faster Pace than
humans evolve because there is actually
an evolutionary process that happens
within our immune cells as they're
dividing there's basically vdj
recombination that basically creates
this extraordinary wealth of antibodies
and antigens against the the environment
and basically all these antibodies are
now recognizing all these antigens from
the environment and they
send signals back that cause these cells
that recognize the non-self to multiply
so that basically means that even though
viruses evolve at millions of times
faster than we are
we can still have a component of
ourselves which is environmentally
facing which is sort of evolving at not
the same scale but very rapid pace
sperm expresses perhaps the most
proteins of any cell in the body
and part of the thought is that this
might just be a way to check that the
sperm is intact in other words if you
waited until that human has a liver and
starts eating solid food and you know
sort of filtrates away
you know uh or or kidneys or stomach et
cetera basically if you waited until
these mutations you know manifest late
late in life then you would end up not
failing fast and you would end up with a
lot of failed pregnancies and a lot of
later onset you know psychiatric
illnesses Etc If instead you basically
Express all of these genes at the sperm
level and if they misform they basically
cause the sperm to then you have
at least on the male side the ability to
exclude some of those mutations and on
the female side as the egg develops
there's probably a similar uh process
where you could you could sort of weed
out eggs that are just not you know
carrying beneficial mutations or at
least that are carrying highly
detrimental mutations so you can
basically think of the evolutionary
process in a nested Loop basically where
there's an inner loop where you get many
many more iterations to to run and then
there's an outer loop that moves at a
much slower pace
and going back to uh uh the next step of
evolution of possibly designing systems
that we can use to sort of complement
our own biology or to sort of eradicate
disease and you name it or at least
mitigate uh some of the I don't know
psychiatric illnesses neurodegenerative
disorders Etc
you can basically and also you know
metabolic immune cancer you name it
simply engineering these mutations from
rational design
might be very inefficient If instead you
have an evolutionary Loop where you're
kind of growing neurons on a dish and
you're exploring evolutionary space and
you're sort of shaping that one protein
to be better adapt that sort of I don't
know recognizing light or permeating
with other neurons Etc you can basically
have a smaller evolutionary Loop that
you can run thousands of times faster
than the Speedy would take to evolve
humans for another million years so I
think it's important to think about sort
of this evolvability
as a set of nested structures that allow
you to sort of test many more
combinations but in a more thick setting
yeah that's fascinating the the
mechanism there is uh for sperm to
express proteins to create a testing
ground early on
uh so that the the failed designs don't
make it yeah I mean in design of
Engineering Systems fail fast is one of
the principles you learn like basically
you assert something why do you assert
that because if that something ain't
right you better crash now then sort of
let it cross at an unexpected time
and in a way you can think of it as like
20 000 assert functions assert protein
can fold assert protein can fold and if
any of them fail that sperm is gone
well I just like the fact that I'm the
winning sperm I have the results of the
winner winning hashtag winning my wife
always plays me this French song that
actually sings about that it's like you
know remember in life we were all the
first one time
so these once at least one time you were
the first